all right if you were in an open field  with an aluminum baseball bat  how many 10 year olds with bike helmets  could you take down before they got you  those kids would be in trouble 10 years  old i'm trying to think what's that like  fourth grade third fourth grade  i'd probably take out at least eight or  nine ten-year-olds with helmets  oh i think you're selling yourself  shorts you think i think you got triple  digits yeah  i mean you do not have triple digits  oh come on you think you could take out  a hundred kids you know how exhausting  that would be  yeah i'm washed you're watched too vital  be gassed after five swings no  if they're coming from all sides one  jumps on your back like another one  climbs on him  i'm down to my knees just trying to  swing that thing and it's over